the reason also a lot of your opponents
are not going to be familiar with this
setup because this is not the main lines
with efore it's not a main line when you
play the full pawn attack you play the
semi system so you play Bishop g5 and
this line is called it's a Smiths law of
Petrossian okay
Smith's law Petrosyan setup this is the
Smiths operation set up against the
Kings Indian defense I think we are
ready to start guys this is the advanced
class okay so this is the advanced class
so and today I'm going to show you a
specific opening okay and I'm gonna show
you a very nice slide that you can play
against a Kings Indian defense you're
playing white and you play d4 right a
chess players can you place excuse me
focus here okay
what are your focus here d4 Knight f6 c4
g6 at the moment we don't know yet which
opening is going to be so because it
could be it could be here
d5 grünfeld defense or it could be
Bishop g7 which is the Kings Indian
defense okay
it could be Greenfeld or it could be
Kings Indian you know so we don't know
at the moment which opening is going to
be okay
so but we're gonna cover now what you're
gonna do against the Kings Indian
defense guys take a seat right sit down
and yeah well what is it what do you
want to say well it's black to move but
yeah Bishop g7 and here we have a very
specific opening that is called Kings
Indian defense thank you
so after the move Bishop g7 now we know
the name of the opening and everybody
the name of the opening is Kings Indian
defense alright
sometimes they refer to as kid Kings
Indian defense okay so and I'm gonna
show you my specialty how to get a good
advantage and try to have a nice
position with the white pieces so I
recommend Knight f3 okay
the reason also a lot of your opponents
are not going to be familiar with this
setup because this is not the main lines
with efore it's not a main line when you
play the full pawn attack you play the
semi system so you play Bishop g5 and
this line is called it's a Smith loss
Petrosyan okay
Smith's love Petrosyan setup this is the
Smiths torpedo sunset up against the
Kings Indian defense so I've been using
this for over 20 years
with some very good results especially
you guys play in a Scholastic level at
the club level played this very
effective maybe not as effective when
you play a grandmasters but very
effective and in other opponents you
know so I use this many many years
successfully so Bishop g5 he plays d6
black now he play III 9b d7 okay now you
play Bishop e7 Bishop e7 he plays c6
okay he plays c6 and now you don't
Castle you play Queen c2 because you're
setting up a little trap here you
setting up a little trap here for your
opponent okay so now pay attention
everybody because you're going to review
this with me so h6 attacking the bishop
Bishop goes to h4 now g5 attacking the
bishop bishop goes to g3 okay Bishop
goes to g3 and now Knight h5 now you can
come forward if you want or you can sit
there so there is a chair here as well
if you like just just turn the chair
[Music]
very good so night h5 now after Knight
h5 now this is a mistake in accuracy who
can tell me why this is a mistake this
is a blunder okay that loses material
this is a blunder I see two hands here
you have tried first Knight takes d5
excellent yes Knight takes d5 it seems
like what is the point this is just
losing upon right but if you take take
the knight this tactic works because of
the loose piece on h5 loose piece okay
so loose piece drops off okay
now if he goes Knight takes g3 if he
goes night xg3
now what is the idea here if he takes
Knight xg3 what you gonna do here to
come up with a mate
many hens I see addict
absolutely checkmate okay very good
got it so please fix this strap okay
it's a very good shop for you to know
and also when you play the move Queen c2
you don't just play for this trap your
Queen belongs there anyway
your queen belongs here and then you're
gonna go queen h7 okay if it takes on g3
you have a mate please take a seat
so let's now let's now review review
this much okay I just want to see if you
guys can get here okay just 12 moves I'm
gonna put in a training load and we're
gonna start from the beginning okay
alright we start with the first move
here you play the moves for white second
move wait wait Oh next person let's give
a chance to everybody to do it next next
person raising hands in the back yes way
it's white to move it's nicely three
Bishop g7 and now everybody play a fort
here but not you you can play this nice
line okay that your opponents are not
gonna be feeling familiar against the
Kings Indian okay which is should be
more hands yes in the back blue shirt
blue shirt
okay guys come on in quickly and close
the doors mm-hm
alright so here
what is the move here yes 9 f3 okay this
is a lecture about Kings Indian defense
how to play against the Kings Indian
defense effectively as white okay now
castles and now you want to try to
activate you need to activate your
Bishop you need to find a way to
activate your Bishop to a good square
okay so who can do it you you ask you
Bishop g5 excellent d6
now yes
III perfect night bd7 now keep
developing you wait wait
Queen or Bishop first you should first
rate and now your move go perfect Queen
c2 you're developing and setting up the
idea and now he plays h6 we're gonna
look at our other line as well the main
line when they don't fall for this trick
but if it plays h6 you retreat
he plays g5 he attacks you you retreat
now he goes Knight h5 Knight is on the
rim and now this is the moment this is
the moment for you to do it white to
play what is the the idea that gives you
material yes
Knight takes g5 sacrificing the night if
he captures what do you do continue
continue your it's on you it's on you go
taking the night perfect and if he takes
the bishop then we go excellent so this
is a very nice trap okay that you have
to keep in mind okay
very very nice trap and you're going to
be able to win the game everybody got it
so there's the Kings Indian defense
Smith's flow of Petrossian okay okay
just players there pay attention here
okay all right so let's go back now and
try to understand what's going to happen
if they don't fall for the trap of
course if they fall for the trap you
guys will like it it will be great you
win but let's say they don't fall for
the trap and they play let's say h6 here
and they play the movie five which is a
move that is expected okay which is
expected move now Newcastle
now they go Queenie seven now we need to
finish our development so in order to
that we have to put the rooks in a good
squares so where do you think we should
put our rooks the white rocks where do
you think they belong where do you think
the rooks belong okay yes yes
no white rooks well the white looks
belong these two guys this one and this
one what is that will be the optimal
squares for this two pieces yeah yeah
where to put them so you want to put
them in a game right
together excellent okay can you tell us
a square specifically perfect rook fd1
rook e8 and now what's your next move
here
when you bring one you bring the second
one in the back yes rook a c1 perfect
now you have every piece developed okay
all the pieces are developed perfect
okay and you're comfortable all right
and the next plan here is he plays b6
now you expand you get some space okay
you how are you gonna get space
very strong very good yes there should
be seven now this is a little loose so I
want to have this protected okay just in
case you know so he doesn't hang at some
point now he plays rook a d1 and now you
try to take he takes and now here is
your idea here in these positions this
d6 square is weak okay this d6 square is
weak so we try to find a way to put a
knight here who can give me a good idea
here how to put a knight - white to play
here
why to play how can you do that
what can we do here addict go correct
yes Knight e4 now threating to play
Knight d6 look at that square and if it
tries to play g5 to attack you now
you're not worried about that boom
because you have a good move right
perfect and then you're attacking this
and attacking this if it takes you take
hitting the rook if it goes away you
come back yes
yes yeah Lexi don't get attracted by
this because if you take the rook you
lose your knight and as you mentioned
that you get you lose two pieces for a
rock and that's not a very good trait
for you okay two pieces for a rock I
just take here he goes here you come
back attacking he goes back you take and
the other night comes in okay so that is
your main line so I want to go back to
it and make sure you remember we left it
up from here you know the sub variation
but I want to also cover the main line
so it's h6 he goes if so it may not be
five and now after plays if I what do we
do here how do we continue in this
position yes
Castle safety of the King is very
important so we get a castle Queen e7
now continue now we continue yes perfect
rooks belong where everybody in the
middle right in the middle now next move
will be more hands should be more hands
yes you correct
b6 now good move good move here because
we want to gain what we want to gain
what space absolutely you gain space by
doing this now he goes Bishop e7 now we
need to strengthen that right yes very
good move yes a3 protecting it okay
strengthening before okay
strengthening before so it's not hanging
later on now he goes here and now this
is the moment we go for a big advantage
we don't hesitate anymore because we
have every piece developed we have what
we call a complete development okay
every piece we have is completely
developed so
now we have every piece develop what are
we going to do here how are we going to
pursue here how are we gonna go for it
okay let's see who has it
okay you go first what do you do first
remember you remember the idea but the
execution needs to be accurate in the
back yes yes perfect you take first he
takes you take he takes and now your
idea comes into play correct what is it
you understand you have to have the line
open okay you have to have the line up
and very important okay we will have an
the line open and then you put the night
there and the night goes on this six ok
so very important to remember that and
now you're threatening to come in if g5
you just go ninety six and if you move
the way we take the bishop and we return
if it doesn't want to allow this let's
say he moves here Knight f8 right now
you you have a strong you can get this D
six square so you can take take and you
play the move C five then you play the
move c5 which is very strong and you're
gonna put the knight on these six okay
c5 you fix it and you put a knight on
the six okay and you can put a bishop on
c4 as well
good okay now we will go over another
line that is crucial
okay and this is one of my games
actually played many years ago in this
I'll destroy the opening part where I
got a big advantage this was a game
against international masters Nikolay
cubanos okay I'm white
so here we got the Kings Indian this
game is played a long time ago but it's
very interesting so III and he played
the aggressive c5 so I played well c5 is
leads to like you don't want to take
here if you take you run into some
queenie 594 ideas so you don't want that
so you play d5 my opponent played very
aggressive maybe was prepared against
this sweep late night h5 but this is
this is aggressive but I don't think is
that good because it weakens the
position a lot ok so this is really
really weakens the position
so I played Bishop d3 in that game
developing my bishop and now he played
'if I've quickly this I already have a
threat here and my trait is to take on
g5 so let's say if you play a six white
wins here white to play and win can you
find the entire winning line here for
white I calculate a little bit a little
bit more whenever you see this night on
h5 it's always a danger for him there is
always a chance that he is going to be
in in trouble ok because of that loose
piece ok this loose piece on h5 now how
are we going to take advantage of that
loose night yes
Knight takes e5 correct so if it takes
back we have Queen h5 correct so he
takes now h6 then he takes well if it
doesn't take you're just up upon you're
really doing great here so if it takes
how are you gonna made him that's what I
want to see I want to see the mating
idea the first move is very important
first move is very very important to
play so we have to force him to the
corner right how are we gonna force him
to the corner yes now he takes sorry
rook to a3 sf5 there yeah Bishop takes
f5 that's a problem yeah he shuts you
down
so let's not sacrifice that let's push
the King to the corner first how you
push the king of the corner all right
now the king is in the corner that's
good he cannot escape to any other
square so now which piece is going to
join in the action which piece you would
like to use to join in the action yes
yeah that's the other person okay so yes
correct
queen a tribe now you threaten to simply
play bishop check and queen h7 mate okay
bishop check we need seven mates the
game so he tries to move this away now
it's very important bishop check he's
gonna escape there so you want to do
something even better even stronger than
that what's hanging now that is crucial
to the position yes correct correct
Queen takes f7 and next we just move the
bishop and it's just going to be a maid
okay
one detail here if let's say he had a
night here on d7 cuz I had this happen
to me so I had somebody played this I
took he took he didn't take the knight
but if he takes
it's the same idea check but you cannot
allow him to play Knight f6 here you
cannot allow him to play Knight f6
because then he'll have a good counter
play so you want to try to control the
f6 square ok you want to try to control
the f6 square how are you gonna do it
how are you gonna control the f6 square
yes excellent correct 94 now you're
controlling the f6 square and you're
still threatening the powerful the
powerful Queen h5 which is coming okay
you understand very important move so if
he does something like this now okay if
he gives you a check you just put the
King on f1 okay just put it on f1 now he
moves the knight wave six what do you do
what do you do Eric he takes continue
Kris stretching okay let's see
Adi yeah now you're threatened check and
check my Radek check a checkmate and he
goes here and now what do you do yes
[Music]
yeah correct correct Queen takes f7 okay
perfect and then you move the bishop
away with the checkmate so so this
Knight g5 is very very important moment
okay here this so keep in mind this idea
so my opponent play d5 thinking you know
I'm just stopping that idea you know
thinking I'm just stopping that idea and
now
I'm Poisson he missed this and he
realized right now that he cannot take
back with the bishop only now he
realized that because if he takes with
the bishop and upon what kind of tactic
White has here that is gonna give him
couple of pawns advantage white wins
couple of pants you do to this tactic
who can see it yes very nice Bishop
takes the six also attacking this to
pawn so it has to do something take and
now continue check that is called
discovery check he takes Queen takes
rook check perfect perfect
yes yeah but then I take on c5 and two
extra yeah two extra funds so my
opponent played Knight takes g3 but now
the bishop is eliminated but I have very
important switching soap right in
between move in between move here what
is that the mid frame of addict he takes
f7 check rook takes I took and I went on
to win this game because I I have extra
pawn
I have extra pawn and his light squares
are pretty weak here so I end up winning
the game comfortably okay so that's the
idea with the Kings Indian okay so I
just wanted you to know this ideas and
probably the best way he should play
here he five is a blunder he should take
and maybe play the move is six I mean
maybe this position is okay for black
but I like White's chances anyway
because King on g8 is a little bit weak
but you can certainly you can certainly
find some games in this position okay
so let's review that idea one more time
so if you play see five everybody what
do we do here
continue d 5 H 6 fish page 4 g5 neither
tribe you should be so we have a serious
threat already right Knight h5 so once
again if it goes 97 this is a blunder I
had this happen to me once in a
tournament in Australia I was playing
about 2200 player and he played this
pool right here and what's the winning
idea go take he has to take otherwise
Queen h5 take back and now he wants to
go 94 so this needs to be prevented and
that's going to be prevented by 94
that's the idea very good so that's the
idea with the Kings Indian okay so
remember this is very good setup for
white and it will give you some really
good chances okay so and the other line
that I wanted to go over with you if you
place the move e5 and it looks like he
protects g5 he is gonna go Queen h5 but
now this is gonna be a problem because
of which move yes
I'm pass on everybody
I'm pass on okay he if he moves two
squares and your pawn is guarding that
square in the original position that's
you can take us if he moved only one
square that's how the AMPA Sun works and
if takes Bishop d6 hitting the rock if
there if it takes Discovery check
winning Queen and if he goes to rook e8
will just take on c5 with two extra
pounds my opponent took here and now in
between move remember check he takes we
take and I I converted this advantage
pretty comfortably Nakamura's games if
you watch Dingley brain games you watch
all the games of Tamura job of your
watch they had a lot of good wins you
know when they march their pants and
attack but this line it's really
effective it stops it okay
[Music]